the attacks came in the early hours of
the morning lighting up the Kei
Skyline The Flash and bang of the
explosions disturbing the Morning Call
of the
birds people were killed and injured as
residential buildings felt the impact of
the
strikes thank God my son was hiding with
his grandmother in the corridor I went
to the kitchen and the shock wve threw
me and a piece of of brick hit me on my
head and I don't know what happened
after
that emergency crews battle to bring the
fires under control not since the early
days of the war has the capital faced
this intensity of bombardment and
despite Ukraine's best efforts using the
air defenses Russian missiles are still
getting
through some managed to get to bomb
shelters but not everyone was able to
escape the rocket hit just in front of
my apartment here lucky that I am alive
I was in the bomb shelter I want to urge
people to go to the bomb shelters
unfortunately my neighbor
died this is the fourth attack on the
capital in 4 days and authorities say
it's the largest since the start of the
war the situation in the city is
difficult almost 70 missiles were
destroyed this was a combined attack
shahad drones including cruise and
Hypersonic missiles the majority of them
were
destroyed Ukraine's Second lodgy City
har was also struck
again less than 70 km from the Russian
border it's bore the brunt of Russian
air strikes over the last few
days experts in Ukraine believe Russia
has been stuck piling weapons in
preparation for this aerial
offensive and no one knows how long it
will continue nor how much more intense
it will get Assad B Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer